-With prominent figures
on the right
embracing and parroting
the dangerous white nationalist
conspiracy theory known
as the Great Replacement,
it's worth noting that,
in addition to being
deeply racist,
bigoted, and dehumanizing,
it's also incredibly stupid.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
You might remember that,
throughout his presidency,
Donald Trump tried
to fan the flames
of a racist conspiracy theory
by claiming that Democrats
were somehow organizing
caravans of migrants
to cross the Southern border
for their own political benefit,
and even handing out cash
to incentivize people
to come to the U.S.
-This is an invasion!
I was badly criticized
for using the word invasion.
It's an invasion.
People hate the word invasion,
but that's what it is.
It's an invasion of drugs
and criminals and people.
Mexico should step up
and stop this onslaught,
this invasion into our country.
The Democrats want
to invite
caravan after caravan
[ Booing ]
of illegal aliens
into our country.
A large group of people.
They call it a caravan.
[ Booing ]
You know how
the caravan started?
Does everybody know
what this means?
I think the Democrats
had something to do with it.
-What is he doing?
Is that like a game
of racist charades?
[ Laughter ]
Is he dealing invisible cards?
Which is something I bet
he tried at his casinos
before they went bankrupt.
[ As Trump ] And that's
[ Laughter ]
a 6 for you, a 6 for you,
and would you look at that?
It's another blackjack
for the dealer.
[ Laughter ]
To no one's surprise,
the racist caravan hysteria
had a habit
of conveniently popping up
during election cycles
and then quietly receding
when the elections were over
because it was obviously
just a cynical tool
to scare people
and stir up Trump's base.
And, as The New York Times
reported in 2018,
it clearly had an effect
on Trump's voters.
As The Times put it...
Including a 75-year-old
Republican in Northern Minnesota
who said she was afraid
that migrant gangs
could take over people's summer
lake houses in the state.
[ Laughter ]
Now, obviously, that's insane.
If we've learned anything
from movies,
it's that,
if you have a lake house,
you don't have to be worried
about immigrants.
You have to be worried
about Jason.
[ Laughter ]
You guys,
the more you focus
on immigrants,
the easier it gets for Jason.
[ Laughter ]
You're pointing your binoculars
toward the Southern border.
Meanwhile, Jason's
just licking his lips,
strolling into your tool shed,
waiting for night to fall.
[ Laughter ]
Picking out one of your tools.
Now, it should be easy
for a healthy political party
in a healthy political system
to condemn white nationalism,
as well as the dangerous
and deeply racist
replacement theory
that comes with it
and, yet, of course,
there are prominent figures
on the right who insist,
while spreading it themselves,
that it doesn't even exist.
-Where, exactly, is all this
criminal white supremacy,
this right-wing domestic
terrorism that poses,
"the most lethal terrorist
threat in the homeland"?
Where is it? Well, of course,
it doesn't exist.
If you were to assemble a list,
a hierarchy of concerns,
the problems,
this country faces,
where would white supremacy be
on the list?
Right up there with Russia,
probably.
It's actually not
a real problem in America.
The combined membership of every
white supremacist organization
in this country
would be able to fit
inside a college
football stadium.
"White supremacy,
that's the problem."
This is a hoax.
-First of all,
you don't have to be
a card-carrying member
of a white supremacist
organization
to be a white supremacist.
It's not Costco.
[ Laughter ]
You can be a white supremacist
without being
an official member,
the same way
you can watch movies
without having
a Blockbuster card.
Although, personally,
I'd give anything
for Blockbuster to come back.
No more sitting in front
of the Netflix home screen,
scrolling for something
to watch.
Back home,
when we had Blockbuster,
I just waited for Mom
to get back from work
and say,
"I got 'Fried Green Tomatoes.'"
[ Laughter ]
And then you'd say,
"I don't think I'm going
to like it, Mom."
And then your dad would say,
"Well, then you can go stare
at the wall!"
[ Laughter ]
So you'd watch it.
And you know what?
I did like it.
I liked it a lot.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks, Blockbuster.
Anyway, can we go back
to this part?
-The combined membership
of every
white supremacist organization
in this country
would be able to fit inside
a college football stadium.
-First of all,
a college football stadium
could fit like 100,000 people,
which is a ton of people.
[ Laughter ]
If I told you, "Don't worry,
I rounded up
all the white supremacists,"
and walked you into here,
I don't think your reaction
would be, "Phew!"
[ Laughter ]
Have you ever watched
a college football game,
or do you just stand outside the
glass at the country club,
watching your rich pals
play squash
with that look on your face,
like you just got to Earth
and you're trying
to understand human behavior?
[ Laughter ]
Second, why don't you just do
some journalism and find out?
It's easy to just ask
open-ended questions
without answering them.
Anyone can do that.
This dude's like a search engine
that just answers your questions
with a series of more questions.
He's...
[ Laughter ]
[ As Carlson ]
I have a question for you.
How big is the cup
and why are the cups
all different sizes?
Why is the government trying
to control you
by telling you how many ounces
[ Laughter ]
you're allowed to have
in one cup?
And, if you're only allowed
to have eight ounces in a cup,
then where are all
the other ounces going?
[ Laughter ]
Are they being stolen
by a secret cabal
of woke elites who are hoarding
all the ounces for themselves
[ Laughter ]
while threatening to cancel you
for daring to question
their authority?
When you ask the barista
at Starbucks
to pour 1,000 ounces of coffee
into your cup,
[ Laughter ]
will they say
that's not possible?
When you climb over the counter
and claim it
your constitutional right
to take as many biscotti
as you want,
[ Laughter ]
will they have you arrested
by the thought police
and put you in a muzzle,
like Hannibal Lecter,
to shut you up because you're
being "annoying as [bleep]"?
[ Laughter ]
Will that happen to you,
just like it happened
to me yesterday?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
But, of course,
he wants to pretend --
he wants to pretend
it's not a problem
because he's also openly
and repeatedly
promoted replacement theory
on his show.
-An unrelenting stream
of immigration, but why?
Well, Joe Biden just said it --
to change the racial mix
of the country.
That's the reason.
To reduce the political power
of people whose ancestors
lived here,
and dramatically increase
the proportion of Americans
newly arrived
from the Third World.
In political terms, this policy
is called the Great Replacement,
the replacement
of legacy Americans
with more obedient people
from faraway countries.
Now, I know that the left
and all the little gatekeepers
on Twitter
become literally hysterical,
if you use the term replacement,
if you suggest
that the Democratic Party
is trying to replace
the current electorate,
the voters now casting ballots,
with new people,
more obedient voters,
from the Third World.
But they become hysterical
because that's --
that's what's happening,
actually.
-Mm.
-Let's just say it --
that's true.
In other words,
you're being replaced
and there's nothing you can do
about it, so shut up!
[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughter ]
-Truly a haunting laugh.
[ Laughter ]
I love the audacity
of calling people on the left
literally hysterical
and then ending one
of your rants
with an insane terror giggle.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Carlson ]
[ High-pitched laugh ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Second, and more important,
the so-called replacement theory
is obviously racist,
dangerous, and dehumanizing,
but on top of everything else,
it's also incredibly stupid.
I mean, just think about it
for like half a second.
No one's being replaced.
There's no capacity limit here.
It's not like there's a bouncer
who only lets two in
when two leave, and yet,
that same bouncer somehow keeps
letting in girls and cool dudes,
even though you
and your friend Todd have been
at the front of the line
for like half an hour.
[ Laughter ]
So, finally, you say,
"Hey, man, you either let us in,
or we're going to FGT!"
And he says,
"What does FGT mean?"
And you say, "Go home and watch
'Fried Green Tomatoes.'"
[ Laughter ]
Then he says, "Oh, man.
Now, I'm never letting you in.
Again, though, just think
about how breathtakingly dumb
the logic here is.
No one gets replaced
when another person
enters the country.
The government doesn't come
knocking on your door and say,
"Hey, someone just
crossed the border,
so now you have to move
to a different country.
We're super sorry.
Pack your [bleep] up.
You're moving to Sweden.
Here's a troll
and a pair of clogs."
[ Laughter ]
Second,
just think about how dumb
and dehumanizing it is
to call migrants who are fleeing
poverty and violence
and coming here to seek
a better life obedient.
They're doing one
of the most difficult things
a human being can do --
uprooting themselves
and their families,
leaving their homes,
and making a dangerous trek
to a foreign country,
and they're doing it
at great personal cost,
in the hopes
of seeking a better life.
For this theory to make
any sense at all,
you'd have to believe
that all those people
are just sitting at home
waiting for a call
from the
Democratic National Committee,
telling them it's time
to join the caravan
and make the trek
toward America.
"Alright, everybody,
pack up your stuff.
I just got the call
from Joe Biden.
We're replacing the Hendersons
and good news --
[ Laughter ]
we're getting their
Blockbuster membership.
[ Laughter ]
Prominent figures on the right
have been parroting
this depraved and deeply racist
ideology for years, now,
and, on top of being bigoted,
dehumanizing, and dangerous,
it's also just
breathtakingly dumb.
It's so dumb, even they can't
actually explain the logic.
They just toss out
racist bull[bleep] and say...
-Does everybody know
what this means?
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.